hello everyone Joey here with another
Injustice 2 clip for you all we've got
the newly playable Black Canary fighting
against Batman and Supergirl here but
there are so many other Fighters left to
be revealed in the game anyone that
you're eager to see an Injustice 2 let
me know in the comments below and don't
forget to hit that like button and
subscribe for more
videos I should have stayed to help
Bruce it's enough you came back Dino
then get ready for me to kick some ass
begin
h
y
[Music]
a Leary
wind
begin
[Music]
down
yeah
[Music]
black
wins
begin
oh
[Music]
get which part of you hurts the
worst you insured for
[Music]
beatdowns
ye
black hariry
[Music]
wins